but for actually doing what Ronald
Reagan talked about in his 1981
inaugural address sort of rolling back
the federal establishment that just
seems not to happen my name is William
vocally I am a contributing editor of
the Claremont Review of Books a visiting
scholar at the Salvatori Center at
Claremont McKenna College and the author
of never enough
America's limitless welfare state so one
thing that the never enough does is to
really sort of break down by looking
over a long historical arc how much the
government has spent and how it has been
spending it but for actually doing what
Ronald Reagan talked about in its 1981
inaugural address sort of rolling back
the federal establishment that just
seems not to happen there are there are
ordinary extraordinary circumstances and
then there are extraordinary
extraordinary circumstances ordinary
extraordinary circumstances are when
something happens and politicians and
people feel well the government must do
something hurricane katrina
the financial meltdown the war in iraq
9/11 the strong impetus then is well we
have to deal with this problem we can
worry about the doctor and we can worry
about the cost we can worry about the
borrowing 5 10 20 30 years down the road
let's deal with this thing now and worry
about that stuff later there has been in
my lifetime one extraordinary
extraordinary circumstance where the
sort of the the economic and political
planets all lined up in a way that we
actually had running government
surpluses and and government was growing
in some ways slower than it ever had
been I'm talking about the late 1990s we
had a Democratic president a Republican
House and Senate we had an economic boom
that nobody really forced saw propelled
by the dot-com revolution and we had in
that sort of what George will calls that
holiday from history between the fall of
the Berlin Wall in 1989 and 9/11 in 2001
we had a rapid build down of a national
defense and suddenly we went from
talking in the early 90s about Kurt
tailing deficit spending to in the late
90s talking about Believe It or Not
surpluses people said as far as the eye
could see the hope that that all those
planets will line up again well that's a
lot to hope for I think to get anywhere
near that level again is we're going to
require not just good luck but a sense a
much more determined effort all around
the denial of the possibility that there
is an end point is I think crucial to
the sort of liberal enterprise that it's
it's not so much that there's an answer
to the question where does this thing
culminate as there is a studied
comprehensive and so far very successful
effort to avoid even addressing the
problem FDR instead of presenting
himself as one of the founders critics
presented himself as their Ally so he
sort of culminated this effort in his
famous 1944 State of the Union address
and just discussed a second bill of
rights the rights to housing and
education and medical care and and sort
of left the door ajar and said and
beyond these rights that I'm listing
there could be additional rights to
social welfare benefits that additional
generations of Americans will decide
they need well once you rights eyes the
welfare state in this way then that has
consequences so when we have a situation
as we did recently here in California
where it turned out that people were
could take their sort of a food stamp
and public assistance kind of ATM cards
and among the places where those were
accepted were casinos on Indian
reservations strip clubs and massage
parlors people are you know the first
reaction was well this is a scandal this
is terrible what could be happening here
but in a certain sense the people who
were taking those cars to those places
were good New Deal liberals in that they
heard the rhetoric about how they had a
right to these benefits and concluded
entirely plausibly hey if I've got a
right to this stuff that means it's mine
that means I have a stronger claim on
holding and using these resources than
anybody else in America
and if I get this card and these
benefits want to take them to the casino
who's to say I can't I think there are a
lot of libertarians who think well we've
been telling people we've been sort of
evangelizing the the Friedman gospel
we've been saying that if if you
understand that big government is is
irreconcilable with with individual
liberty and you tell people about this
eventually they will understand and they
will vote out the rascals they will vote
out the big government welfare state
regulators and the fact that we've been
evangelizing and this hasn't happened
means it can only mean that we haven't
been evangelizing energetically enough
so if we double down if we try harder if
we if we hold more seminars and and get
the Road to Serfdom or capitalism and
freedom in front of more readers
eventually we'll succeed well you know
eventually might not be soon enough I
mean I'm so I think that that
libertarians that they face a painful
dilemma if they step back and take stock
of the historical trend if they want to
make a historical difference they need
to entertain the possibility of
unpalatable compromises that may
nevertheless be the only alternatives to
sort of politically self marginalizing
themselves
like a liberal up at 2:30 in the morning
and say why do we have a welfare state
the first answer you'll get is well
because we have to help people who are
poor America pushed back against this in
a laudable and important way with the
law that the Republican Congress passed
in 1996 and Bill Clinton eventually none
too happily signed there was a sort of a
nationwide commitment to the idea that
welfare should be as as President
Clinton said many times as a candidate
for office and then as a president it
should be a helping hand but not a way
of life you know and I think a lot of
conservatives were very satisfied with
that that sort of political breakthrough
and really felt that both the abolition
of as a program and the D legitimization
as an idea of welfare was a settled
question that we were not going to go
back there but it's it's not quite so
settled we saw that once the Pelosi
Congress with a Democratic president
settled in in 2009 with this economic
crisis one of their first things was to
immediately begin instituting many of
the provisions that people thought had
been abolished permanently with the
demise of of AFDC I think there are
still a lot of liberals who view the the
1996 law abolishing AFDC as a temporary
rather than a settled question and think
that this is a battle that they are
going to live to fight again and win and
and I think there there will again be an
audience of people who are not ashamed
about are reluctant about receiving such
benefits